all right let's get into it uh
good day everyone
and welcome to uh another episode of
this past weekend
um
what's going on happy
belated easter
if you did it
if you did easter man then you probably
know what i'm talking about or if you
enjoy easter
hmm
don't let the lord lick you where the
good lord what they used to say don't
don't
i don't know what they said
but here we are um
happy easter happy belated easter
ah
and let's get into this episode
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh that's a little slow boy that'll make
you damn kill yourself at a wedding
right there that thing sounds a little
that's a little slow i'm sorry i'm
trying to find some easter easter easter
music
and easter don't have a lot of good
music that's another thing you know
easter don't have a lot of good music
most of it's at church you got to go to
church to hear it
let's try one more here we go
[Music]
hmm
oh that drum comes in
that drum comes in and doesn't even help
[Music]
yeah that's a little that's bad when the
drum comes in and doesn't even help
you know
that sound like a little maybe like an
elementary school band at a um on the
titanic or something like damn you know
the second they start up this
this band is going down boy
[Music]
oh yeah
yeah you could hear the water i mean you
could you could see the water rising
outside of the classroom windows right
there that thing
that's a real sinker's anthem right
there
i think
what is it i'm trying to find it there
one more good track for easter
music here let me see what i can do for
us
try to find one more
um
[Music]
there we go baby
[Music]
that's got a little more lift in it
whenever you're down
out in the cold
faithless and dark
your story's untold
come take my hand come on and walk there
with me
i know a
can be place
let's go baby
[Music]
[Music]
come on now
[Music]
is
[Music]
can't you see you will be free and
that's a beautiful little tune right
there i just found that and that is
there is a light by the stone keepers
and that band they play some stuff it
seems like uh
something you could wash a baby to
really that's what you want let's hear
them again it's just instrumental here
with this hitter
[Music]
come on now
[Music]
oh yeah
tuck your junk baby tuck your junk and
feel something
um
you don't need a bra ladies let the lord
hold your tits ladies come on
and big fellas
come on
[Music]
there you go that's something you could
wash a dang baby too right there
[Music]
you could just see the water going over
his little back
[Music]
that's something you could wash a baby
too right there you know even wash under
his thick little arms right there
you know just get up damn you just want
to just clean that little sucker out get
the devil out from under his arms
when i was young they used to tell you
that if you stank real bad as he got the
devil under your arms boy
and as a kid you'd smell under your arm
you're like dang something is going on
under there
i do have something non-well
festering under me
you know
i do have something uh
you know i got a little dark arts garden
under each pit
under each flapper under each lifter
under each arm
what's going on yeah i hope you had a
beautiful easter time i had a nice time
myself i hope you are uh
you know wherever this this um episode
finds you today if you're in your car if
you
sit in at home maybe
having you a little soup or something
you know maybe on a lunch break
and you got a sandwich
and some people look some people cut
their sandwiches
and that that's me i cut my sandwich up
you know i do the four cut
some people do their sandwich they don't
do any cut they just bite into it just
blindly
just know
there's not a real game plan it's very
those people that's a real question mark
fella right there or strong woman
somebody who don't they're the sandwich
they this but it's more that attack dog
style you know
i'm just going to get in that [ __ ] get
in there
but i like that more that one that's
been more dissected
you know you always knew how much
somebody mom loved them when they were a
kid if they if that sandwich had been
really clipped up
you know and sometimes you know yeah
because your mom your mom if you if your
mom really loves you cut that thing you
know nice and
and then you had them you know
them regular boys out there
and they that [ __ ] you know
that thing look there's no plan to get
into that thing
that's sandwich looks like he doesn't
even want you to get into it sometimes
if you look at it that way
and that's certainly when i was yeah
when i was young i had that kind of
thing was
that thing was uh
didn't have a lot of entry points on it
a lot of those sandwiches we had um
what's going on man oh
yeah there's always that person at lunch
that pulls that bad bastard out
you're like damn boy
this dude
this dude is going through some stuff
that sandwich doesn't have anything
going on with it
and sometimes some people's mind would
cut the heart in the middle be like damn
they must be rich bruh
if somebody had that heart cutting that
sin like they must be rich
and sometimes they were
that's that's the real kicker there
sometimes they were
um
yeah happy belated easter man hope
everybody had a nice time i hope
everybody got to at least sit and spend
time with a loved one
you know got to be around somebody that
they cared about and
and uh do something joyous
i went down to louisiana
which is a beautiful place down there
man
it's a slower place
you get down in louisiana man a half
hour will take 45 minutes
ain't nobody in a rush to get through
that that
somebody start a sentence at 11 a.m and
finish it up at about 12 20. like damn
dang boy mr eddie really got a gift of
gab they say
but it's a real you know it's just a
slow going
you see somebody start yawning and
somebody start yawning about 4 15 in the
afternoon
and they won't stop till about 5.
this is a slow pace
it's just that you know it's that kind
of place um
things take time
and people even a hug takes time you hug
somebody that thing gonna last a minute
or two you could
take a small nap if you want
you know you hug somebody it's just
people there's not as much of a hurry
there's a little more patience there's a
little more peace
docility
you know there's something nice about
that
there's something nice about the
relaxation of it and it's sweaty too
down there though
you get down into louisiana you get down
into some of these rural areas baby you
know what i'm talking about as sweaty as
can be
sometimes it's hard to hug some people
now
if they look thick or if they got a
little bit of oil in their skin or you
know
or if they too small you can't even get
a hug on somebody if they real bony like
i can't
you can't
it's impossible
[ __ ] you can't really get a good snatch
on them
because everybody's sweating down there
people so sweaty
you know you see people try to shake
hands and
20 times a hand slide right off can't
even somebody put a watch on it can't
get it on damn
because of the sweat pouring out of
people
you know there's just a lot going on
down there uh but we had a nice time
we had a real nice time man uh
it was uh
what was it it was
you know when i was in high school i
went and lived with a different family
and
the fellow that raised me that man uh or
who was part of my life he turned 80
years old
and he getting older baby now
so we went down there and had his
birthday and that was really nice
and then uh
went over to my brother's house for
easter
and they had some good food over there
baby
what they have they had um
them
weiner
bla uh
it's like wiener blanket
ed uh
it's not like a it's like a little
wiener blanket uh
it looked like a piece of bread put a
rear naked choke on a damn uh lil wayner
you know what i'm talking about it's
look like um
yeah
it's like uh
you know what i'm talking about it's
just like a little
it's like a little wiener is wearing a
little uh french bread as like a cape
i don't know what it's called
but they had a whole little stack of
them mitch's and i got in there
and they had those finger sandwiches
somebody brought a tray at them
and i cracked into them and some of
those
you know the meat the the the more the
afternoon goes on that meat gets a
little hard
and that's kind of when you find out who
you are as a man i think is uh
the later in the afternoon you're
willing to eat a finger sandwich
because you see some dudes get real
dicey with it too some guys will only
roll in later in the day 5 p.m or
something around sundown and it was a 1
p.m party
and then [ __ ] it gets real hard on
the outside
on those little fingers sound a little
bit of ham on that bastard
you know a little bit of rotts beef
someone i just
and some men they go tongue first into
that [ __ ] some of those older man that
[ __ ] is like damn bruh
y'all need to lock that man up
or at least go through his hard drive
that dude is on to he's been doing you
know that guy's got something going on
in him
because his tongue is out here he's out
here tongue first into the world looking
for something
but if you see somebody go tongue first
into the hard side of a finger sandwich
dear god maybe lock them up that's what
i say
lock them up um
but yeah we had a nice time and we had a
really nice time uh
what else did we do
um
i'll tell you i'll tell you i want to i
got some new tour dates i want to tell
you too so don't forget
i'm excited to let you know uh we got an
extra show added in los angeles on may
7th
that's coming up over there at the will
turn
and then we got albuquerque new uh new
mexico
and that's may 18th may 19th in midland
may 20
in lubbock
and may 21 dallas texas we've added
another show there
so get your friend or somebody get
somebody you love and bring them grab
somebody by the hand and say hey babe
we're gonna go get involved in something
good
we also have savannah georgia june 2nd
augusta
georgia june 3rd and montgomery alabama
june 4 as well as columbus georgia june
5.
and some uh those are all available
theovon.com tour
and some new dates down in florida
we are we have june 23rd in hollywood
florida
june 24
fort myers florida down there military
area i'm guessing
and june 2-5 over in daytona beach
florida
if you come over there bring them
sunburnt titties out with you
and bring that skin cancer with your
baby in daytona
everybody out there smoking on them door
aisles
and huffing on winston's
you'll see a newborn come out and he got
his uh
he'll have a little lighter in his hand
hunting the door out
that's daytona beach florida june 2-5
june 2-6 down there in lakeland
florida
and those florida tickets are available
first to patreon
on tuesday april 19th
um and they'll we'll send you the code
on patreon and then the uh my pre-sale
starts wednesday april 20th
and that code is rat kang at 10 am
locally you can get those
um
and that starts on wednesday so yeah as
well we have got some new stuff we got
the bobble heads on sale and the gang
gang hoodies are out now as well
and you can find all those online um
and just thank everybody for the support
you know uh and thank you for supporting
this podcast and being patient with this
podcast
uh and just being a part of of this
group
um
yeah i'll get back into a little bit
more about easter
you know i went and spent some time my
family and uh and we really enjoyed
ourselves but i also want to get into
the news a little bit the news right
here
um
a man
a man
an adult male
told his employer not to celebrate his
birthday
and uh he was awarded 450 000 after he
received an unwanted party
and that's where we are folks it says a
kentucky man
with anxiety disorder
asked his employer not to celebrate his
birthday because it would trigger a
panic attack damn bro
damn man now he could have had a rocky
birth that's the thing you get you don't
know
and sometimes you do know when you shake
somebody's hand you look in the eye you
can see all the way back to the womb
baby
straight back to that mom hole and you
can see that they really struggle on the
way out
some babies they come out that [ __ ] fat
they
[Music]
they they don't want it you know it's
been a tough time it's been a long nine
months they did
they've been in there shaw shanked out
baby they couldn't handle it inside of
their mom
because sometimes you don't know what's
going on in the womb
because the others you know we see the
the the the human side
but the back side of the womb that's the
lord's that's you know
that's the lord's lobby dog that's that
bts we don't know what's going on in
there
so that baby could have been in there
you know could have been caged up could
have been they could have had ms-13 back
in there they could have had a couple
brothers in there shanking out doing
dice you don't know what it's been like
in there it could have been a you know
some vatos running a fake church you
know you don't know what the backside
of the womb has been like for a baby
what the lord's side has been
because that sonogram that just picks up
you know
that's just it picks up the earth side
so damn bro you and you know so some
babies they come right out that [ __ ]
and they don't want to be in the world
really and sometimes you see a man and
so when he
that birthday just brings all that back
it triggers it
you know when some people these days
they got a lot of fire [ __ ] out there
they can't handle seeing a little bit of
fire
so you put more than four candles on a
sugar treat they [ __ ]
they lose their edge you know
so maybe that's what happened i don't
know it says um
anxiety disorder man asked his employer
not to celebrate his birthday it would
trigger panic
when the accompany when the company
ignored kevin burling's request
and at a surprise lunchtime celebration
he got upset had a panic attack and left
work
now this is the part of you panicking
that much i don't know if you could
where you drive off or did he walk off
if he walked off i believe it
but if you really panicked out you can't
operate a damn dodge neon or not you
know you can't
if you really shook i don't know you
know it's hard to really i wouldn't get
into a motor vehicle
a day after the celebration burling
was called into a meeting where he was
confronted and criticized for his
reaction
damn they probably lit him up he ca you
can't handle his birthday kevin
uh
uh kevin
you can't handle a surprise party son
this confrontation triggered another
panic attack the lawsuit said he was
fired days later damn bro
burling sued alleging disability
discrimination and retaliation on march
31 a jury awarded him 450 grand
he suffered an adverse employment action
because of his anxiety disability damn
that's where we are people people can't
handle a surprise party
people can't handle a surprise
and i i i look i got a side with the
company here man
i gotta side with the company because
mr burling if you
it's your birthday man you were the one
that was born bro
okay
so
these people are trying to honor that's
what they do at an office if there's a
kitchen
with a table in it
at a business
then the only thing people do in there
is use the microwave
or do surprise cakes for other people in
the office man
you gotta know that [ __ ]
if you even go there to work
you gotta know that people wanna they
wanna
and it's not even about you it's about
the other people at work they want a
12-minute break
to have some bad cake from albertsons
okay
they want to have an extra 11 or eight
minutes during one day of the week
to surprise they probably don't even
know your name mr burling
so it's really a chance for you to kind
of show out
so when you i think when you go into a
group setting and you say look i don't
want to do the thing that y'all do
[Music]
and then they do it and you go to the
car with the panic attack man
it's your birthday you were born bruh
i think you got to come to term i think
you got to talk to your mother about it
or you got to talk to somebody about it
because if they candle you up and get
that sugar
that's a that that that's all it is man
yeah can you
can you even imagine where kevin's like
don't throw me apart look guys
don't throw me a party okay
i mean it guys do if somebody
secretly comes around the corner
with the cake for any reason
i'm out of here
like what happened to him that he can't
handle like what kind of trauma happened
to him i just i don't understand
how you can't handle a dessert
and ta-da at the same time i just don't
i don't get it
i don't get it but that's where we are
but that's where we are
and a day after the celebration
burling was called into a meeting where
he was confronted and criticized
hey bro
we was trying to surprise you
and he couldn't take it man and he
triggered another panic
attack that's the fun it's like is it
just panic attack are you just upset
maybe that's another thing
we've gotten into a place where even if
you're just a little upset people call
it a panic attack so damn but he got
that 450 grand
watch him throw himself a huge birthday
party now too
watch kevin burling go hard bro
dang he suffered adverse employment
action you could sue for anything now
imagine suing because people wanted to
show you love on your birthday
maybe he hated those people
maybe he hated working there
i bet that's what it was
because if you hate working somewhere
then when those people are celebr are
trying to get a little bit of a
12-minute break because of your life
because you were born
you're going to say no no
we shutting it down i bet that's what
happened
damn boy
but everybody knows his name now kevin
burling's got 450k on him so
somebody gonna surprise that dude with a
weapon or something i mean that's a lot
of money
what else we got in the news michigan
kendra gartner
michigan kindergartner brings jose
cuervo margaritas to snack time made
students woozy
that's michigan bro have you been to
michigan
that's michigan dude
that's mixed that's mexican michigan
really that's all they doing
a kindergarten class accidentally
consumed tequila during snack time
one of the kids bought a bottle of
ready-to-drink jose cuervo margaritas to
grand river academy
so you know if academy is in and it's
rich children
in her backpack she brought it rich
several students drank it bro thoughts
probably
one kindergartner felt woozy and a
little dizzy
some little lightweight after having
four or five sips from a dixie cup this
sounds like uh
this sounds like a morgan walling
concert are they what was going on here
but
what else
that's the news
okay we got uh i want to tell you this
that right now this episode is sponsored
by ritual
protein powders can be intimidating but
the fact is that we all need protein
look at an animal
what's in it
protein if you pet an animal what do you
feel under its skin protein
it's not just about muscles protein
helps support
bone health and satiety satiety as we go
through life protein needs change so
it's important to choose a mix for
different life stages
rituals essential protein
is a delicious plant-based protein
powder with three distinct formulas
designed to meet the body's changing
protein
needs
choose from three thoughtful formulas
with 20 grams of pea protein per serving
daily shake 18 plus
is a complete amino acid profile
featuring
choline
an essential nutrient and common dietary
gap
if you ladies been giving out uh babies
out of your body
or men if you can do it i'll watch you
try
they are that shake is formulated with
extra nutrient support to meet the
demands of pregnancy and lactation
they have a great taste handcrafted
vanilla flavor from sustainably
harvested madagascar vanilla bean
and i don't know how they get it
probably kind of want it in a war i'm
not sure where they get it
ready to shake up your protein ritual
my listeners get 10 percent off during
their first months at ritual dot com
slash theo
ritual even act offers a money back
guarantee if you're not 100 percent in
love visit ritual ritual
dot com slash t-h-e-o for ten percent
off your first three months
i want to let you know about blue chew
as well you know about it probably
but you can know more blue chew is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost
blue chews tablets combat all forms of
ed
and can help men
gain extra confidence for when it's time
to perform
they get you ready they get you rotted
out
blue chew is an online prescription
service
so no doctor visit no awkward convo no
waiting in line at the pharmacy it ships
right to your door in a discreet package
yup don't like swallowing pills and no
problems here
the
sildenafil
and the tata lawful
tablets are chewable
so you can
just eat them
uh blue chews are made in the usa so
there you go
you could listen to damn um
you could listen to some bruce
springsteen while you eat that bastard
and guys here's a special deal for you
try blue chew free when you use our
promo code th eo at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w
dot com promo code
t-h-e-o to receive your first month for
free
all right um
yeah
easter came through you know and uh
and jesus came back
you know he's that real
i mean he's the hide and go seek champ
really
when you think about it
and i really like easter
you know i like the tradition i like you
go and you see you get your little cut
of ham on the plate
and get you a ham medallion or whatever
they got over there
your cut some people do it different
some people cut the ham in an easter
shape or something you might get a
little rabbit ear
of ham or you might get your little uh
you know sometimes somebody will cut
a piece of ham even in like a little
chickadee
you're like damn this is chicken and ham
you know but it's really just ham
um
and i like a lot of the traditions that
come along you know i like easter i like
seeing the different colors and you
drive by a church and there's some kids
out there
and so you know couple of kids sometimes
for their brothers they're fighting when
i'm punching the other one
but still they look nice
you know the girls have their little
dresses on and they're
you know the mom is talking to somebody
and saying bye we had a nice time and
the girls are sitting there just hanging
on her dress they're all ready to go
back to the house
you know i just like driving but i like
just seeing things like that i like
going to a service and people are
singing and
but i like the tradition of it man
and i like the fact that jesus comes
back i like the fact that he somebody
shows back up to check on you
yeah
jesus is like that bookmark
in time
you know he's that recurrer he's that
that
you know he shows back up he's
hey i haven't forgot about you
hey haven't forgot about you
you know i like that
i like that man um
because time is just
time has no
feeling
you know time i mean time is sometimes
so it's so painful
because it doesn't time don't stop for
nothing
time don't stop for nothing
not a birth not a death
not a uh
surprise part-time not a
car crash not a fire not a
time don't stop for it nothing
you know how cold you gotta be
to not stop for nothing
you gotta be as cold as can be
you gotta have the north pole in your
nuts
you gotta have a damn polar bear
living in your heart
and that's time man
time just keeps going
and so i i that's why i like traditions
i like things that are like uh little
things that give you
just little bookmarks
and i like that jesus pops back and he
said hey i'm you know i'm gonna be i'll
be back you know
uh you know i'm still here
i like that
he's like the terminator
you know he's like this one thing that
says hey time i'm gonna
he's almost like this little bit of like
a trump card for time
he's like all right time i see you but
just know that i got my own super powers
and i can cut you know
i can come back and change the game
so that's one thing that i find real
inspiring about the
about the easter story is that there's
some
con it's it provides some comfort
because time is not uh
time is uh
i mean time don't even stop to tie his
shoe it don't even know if it has shoes
on
it don't know if it's in sandals or
boots if or if it even has legs
time don't even stop to look down to see
what it's rolling on
if it's on damn wooden wheels or
24s or
or ankles it does it doesn't
it just keeps going
you know it's just like a just a
thoughtless
wind
but we need it
and that's why i like the easter story
that's why i like uh jesus christ
popping back through and saying hey
just letting y'all know when i when i'm
ready to come back and do my magic i'm
gonna come back and do my magic you know
it's nice that somebody pops in
it's like when you're playing and you're
a kid and somebody sticks her head in
the door and like hey
letting y'all know i'm here
so i like that you know i like that
every year somebody rolls back through
and says hey time i see you doing your
thing
but just letting you know i can do mine
as well
and that's a beautiful story there um
and our families i don't know what
religion we were growing up i don't know
we
i don't know i mean we live close to a
church we were six baptists or something
i think or seventh baptist i don't
we live right by a church
and somebody definitely i'm not saying
got molested but
somebody you know
somebody in our family probably got my
list
so we're whatever religion that is baby
you know what i'm saying
and uh
and yeah i like traditions
i like traditions because the more we
lose traditions um the more we lose
contact with uh
our forefathers and stuff
it really is you know and i know some
people like well a lot of traditions are
just business
right but it's not about that really
it's about the fact that you celebrate
something that
someone else celebrated
that you
you try and tell like this relentless
thing this
time that doesn't even get
you know time doesn't even give it gives
you life but you're like it's so
it's so hard to really make an imprint
in time
it's almost impossible
but for me i feel like small things like
traditions and celebrating certain
things every year
it's a little bit like saying uh
i'm gonna try to put my stake in the
ground here
yeah i don't remember what religion we
were man uh
growing or what
denomination
um
but
i remember one christmas somebody
had driven through a fence
in our area somebody had a fence
and somebody had driven through it
because people
you know get jealous and [ __ ] and drunk
and like oh this motherfucker's got a
fence bam you know
and somebody drove through that [ __ ]
and um
and so they
i went over there one time and was
hanging out with one of the kids over
there
and we started making uh stuff out of
wood
and i made my sister this um
like a thing to keep her dolls in or
something i was probably about maybe 11.
so then i remember i'm walking home one
night and i passed this family's house
they had they had a rental home right on
the corner
and this man that lived there was elvis
impersonator
he had four children i think and they
all stayed in the yard and wore like
i think they were pentecostal they wore
clothes all the way down past their feet
i mean it looked like there was just
look like they were sleeping bags with
heads you know the whole family
and
uh the daddy was in the garage making
one of the children a shirt out of wood
and he was alcoholic
and i went in there and i remember and
tried to help him put that together for
his son for christmas
and his son used to vomit on the bus
and i don't even know if you ever got an
education i don't know what the hell
class even went to i just remember
one thing i remember about the kid is
that he had uh
he was losing his hair at a young age
and he used to vomit on the bus he was
basically like a 50 year old man like he
was almost like an older alcoholic the
kid but he was just a kid
all right let's get into a few questions
and stuff that came here as always the
hotline is 985-664-9503
if you're having trouble with something
or you're struggling with something feel
free to hit the hotline
if you have a question if you have a
response or
reply or replication about something on
the show
feel free to hit it you know it's uh
it's an open airwave game
what's up ceo it's michael uh
i don't know if you remember me or not
but i called
a little over a year ago
on the spill the duntin let's um build
the donut episode
thank you for calling michael from the
spill the duntlin episode i have to go
back and check that out man but i
appreciate you calling brother homeward
i had just
relapsed
and uh you called me back then and
talked with
kind of lifted my spirits up
and uh i'm sorry i'm out of breath i'm
at work but uh so anyway
it's been a little over a year now and
uh
i'm still clean uh no relapses
i'm happier than i've ever been
everything's good so
i just wanted to give you an update and
let you know everything is good and i
think a lot of it has to do with
you calling me that day
it meant the world to me and i just
wanted you to know that you're a good
dude man
well thanks bro i appreciate the nice
message man um
you know that's sweetie to say man uh
[Music]
you know i think as a lot of that goes
to you
for just taking care of yourself it's
tough and to try something new and try
something different is tough
and um
yeah and thank you for just reaching out
and saying the nice words you know i'm
happy for you
you sound uh
good
and that's nice that's a nice way to
sound brother amen
uh let's hit another call or two that
came in
um
here we go this one actually this is
kind of in the same vein
hey theo my name is robert i just wanted
to want to call in say hey let you know
i appreciate you man i've been listening
to you for the last
last few years and
honestly i don't know why i really know
why i'm calling
thanks for calling robert and that's
long for robbie people say robbie or rob
bob
uh robo they call him sometime
uh
robert
i think it's french actually robert
robert
somebody that's roberting
it's not a verb
onward
um
i think you're really relatable
as far as human being a human being so i
wanted to get your opinion
um
kind of about my first real stint of
sobriety right now and
i'm about to come up on my 90-day mark
and the first part was real easy even
now i'm starting to have these
conversations in my head
where i'm negotiating with myself that
you know maybe i'm not an alcoholic
trying to work through my steps and
stuff
i'm getting closer and closer to talking
myself into reaching for the bottle
again
i just wanted to to get your opinion and
see if there's anything that can really
be
anything
thanks for the call man um
yeah i think you're what you're
expressing is what a lot of people
express if they are about to
um
go out of their program you know and not
uh
be
sober
so
it's a risk it's a tough it's a risky
place to be in
because yeah there will be things that
will call you back into the world it's
happened to me many times you know um
i'm just recommitting myself now to my
program and um
i just hit a meeting this morning
uh
and there's a lot of old people in this
meeting and some of them like start
falling asleep and like one guy i think
was in the war i guess i don't even know
what war
it could have been but
he'll like
[Music]
and other guys are just old so they just
have sounds kind of come out of them you
know
like
[Music]
you know like some of them and then uh
you know old people sometimes like like
a gas will just come out of their arm
you know they just
their bodies just kind of
you know it's like a hot spring kind of
almost at a certain point where they're
just little
you know they'll move their elbow and
it'll just like a get like a not like a
an exhaust it just their fault you know
it's just a lot of old people are making
all these sounds around me it sounds
there's a lot of sounds in there um
but anyway yeah i just
was just thinking about that but um
yeah look the only thoughts i have is
this it's really tough to recommit
yourself once you start going down that
slope you know um
you know i've tried a lot of different
things over time uh
thinking that i didn't have some sort of
problem or not knowing what my problem
or not knowing what my
not problem but difficulty was uh
so
i mean it's all your own choice
you know nobody can tell you what to do
but
it's definitely your i've seen the
crossroads a bunch and i've been there
myself where you kind of lean in or
you're leaning out
um
[Music]
you know but i applaud you on 90 days
brother congratulations man that's
awesome and i just wish you the best
whatever you're doing
you know and nobody knows if you are an
alcoholic or if you have the that thing
or some
form of it except for you you're the
only one that knows
you know
so
love you baby take care of yourself
brother gang
um
what else we had some other good calls
that came in here uh
oh yeah let's hit this one
hey theo this is brendan uh
out of new hampshire
by way of boston
and um i was just calling in because i
feel i really can relate
some of your family troubles man like
so you've been talking about your mom
and
i have a similar issue with my mom i uh
you know i'm not gonna get into it
because it's not pretty but
sometimes your your trust goes away and
um my dad was he was never really you
know
in the scene he was doing his own thing
he's like
he's a hyper-intelligent in individual
and um he wasn't there for me but
to have my
my my trust broken from my mom made me
feel like i had no one really so i
looked up to my older brother
and um i was just wondering you know
is is forgiveness in us because i try to
forgive so much but then oftentimes i
dwell on you know
why
why they wronged me and this goes for my
brother my dad my mom
yeah this is a good call man i
appreciate it uh thank you for calling
and um
it's funny this is kind of right where i
am you know during the holiday during
easter i got to see my mother and see my
brother and
um my mother's gonna be moving to
arizona
and uh
you know this may have been the last
time i get to see her
in um
in louisiana
you know and uh
and she's moving to tucson arizona
um
and she also oh she's trying to get a
weapon too so if anybody does tactical
sales or tactical training out there
that can help like an older woman do it
um hit up the producer email
because we got to get mom uh
we got to get that thing on you know
so um
and she had to be a piece that she could
handle you know so
uh that would be awesome if somebody
could could um
you know help help with that that'd be
cool
um
yeah uh
it's tough because it's like yeah how do
how long do i hold a grudge you know
and then
because at a certain point your parents
they're just getting older and you're
missing out on whatever there is there
um
and yeah i think i i believe
and it's one of the reasons why i'm
trying to recommit myself to my program
is because i believe that forgiveness is
the only
answer
i believe that
letting go of whatever that hurt is
you know sometimes i felt so hurt as a
kid i felt the
i hold on to that hurt because sometimes
it's the only relationship i had
with my mother was uh
that i was angry at her
you know and it's all i had it's all
it's the only thing that i had so it was
like so hard to let it go it's been hard
to let it go
because the only thing that i had
uh
was my
anger or my uncomfort or my pain it was
so hard to let it go
it's like a blanket you know it's a
it's like i know this isn't good for me
but somehow it keeps me warm a little
you know the only thing i had we know
when i was young
and i'm not
talking about self-pity here or anything
like that i'm just i'm trying to really
examine this like
why we hold on to those things
um
because yeah all i all for a long time
all i had was my just my anger
and my i was wronged my that that you
know it's somebody's all i had was that
and when you have that from a young age
with a parent it's
um
that's
like it's not even you holding on to it
as a conscious adult it's this [ __ ]
sh it's this inner child that's got this
claws on him you know
he got them grips
the mitts baby
and so it's hard to let go of some of
that um
but i i just i just believe that the
only way to do it the only way to really
get free is to have some forgiveness you
know
and uh people do the best they can
you know i saw my mother this weekend
and uh
and all any of us are is just kids that
are just getting older
you know and just trying our best in the
world
um
and sometimes it takes time you can't
really force it you know but uh
but i think we can get into practices
that help us get closer to forgiveness
and um
and that's where i want to be
because at a certain point i'm tired of
uh
[Music]
of the grudges i'm
even if i'm not the one making them even
if they're from a young i've gotta talk
to myself or have a relationship enough
with my heart
that's like hey trust me enough
to walk us through this
and with my higher power
to say hey god help me get help me walk
through this
you know help me
you know i have felt unloved or i have
felt wrong or i have felt this help me
try again
to give this person a chance to love me
because if not
i miss out twice
i miss out as a child
when i didn't wasn't able to make a
choice
when i when when
when i had it was all survival instincts
that i had to to operate from
but i miss out as an adult when i am
able to make a choice
and uh
and as hard as it is i don't want to
miss out on getting to love my mother
twice
you know um
and i don't know if that makes a ton of
sense or not and
[ __ ] i don't even know if i care if it
does
uh
you know it's been for me it's been a
long journey with this kind of stuff and
and and trying to navigate it and
and that's okay
you know um
[Music]
that's okay so
but i wish you well there brother and uh
and just know that there's other people
out there that are on this journey with
you in some ways
it could be a mother it could be a
father it could be could be a sibling
and it could be ourselves
sometimes a lot of it for me is about
forgiving
myself
you know when you are
as children you think it's your fault
you you know you take some respect you
take so much responsibility for yourself
that if something isn't right then of
course it's on me it's on me
um
[Music]
but if if stuff's on you for so long
it's on me it's on me it's on me you can
handle that for a while but i think at a
certain point you're right it's all on
you
and it's just you
and it gets kind of lonesome you know
and i'm not saying that in a self-pity
way i'm just saying that and like
you know i want my life to be filled
with other people and um
and so that's hopefully that is a
direction that i can
uh
head in you know with the help of others
and with the help of a higher power
um
you know i've been there before and uh
and i think i can be there again
but gang gang baby take care of yourself
oh yeah and i got this new gang gang
hitter right here too on it's a baby
blue and it's a large
and the large one's a little big on this
one
so
i don't know if i'd go medium i feel
good in here
uh
i feel like somebody should have washed
under this baby's arms so that's for
damn sure
and if you can't get well brother you
can always get you one of them weighted
blankets
if you can't get well you could always
get you a weighted blanket
because that's like that's one thing i
noticed some people they you got that
you know they get that weighted blanket
they gotta feel
and i'm one of those people [ __ ] i don't
know what i'm talking about
i like to get that little
um make me feel like a little peanut
just tidy me up
i always want to be wrapped up and you
know
smothered covered chunked baby put me
like
that i wanna i want them covers right up
to mine i want it all
i gotta be tight tight
that's how i like to be
you know but i had a friend that was
visiting him recently and they're like
oh yeah the weighted blanket she said
the weighted blanket in your guest room
is great
i said i didn't know i had a damn
weighted blanket in there
and uh
and that's where i guess you know
maybe we're all headed that way
i think the world we there's so much
anxiety in the world now everybody's
gonna have a weighted blanket weighted
hat
you see somebody in a damn weighted hat
brother can't even walk
i'm just trying to get to work
my my nephew got me this heavy one you
know and that dude just trudging along
barely he's nine minutes late to work
over there at
amazon it's up you know everybody get
everything weighted gloves you can't
even shake a hand anymore but you don't
know no anxiety
people can have a cn they're going to
have a service friend
why that's what i'll probably be i'll be
that emotional support friend
i'll be that emotional support friend i
won't be the friend that the the chicks
bang
that dude will come in he'll be that
real hit man probably a little votto or
something or a brother you know
somebody with some tats and uh you know
maybe a blade on them
but um
i'll be that emotional support friend
that kind of comes in and just kind of
chats with you while you're making
dinner
you know that's what i'll be
but that it's getting weird in the world
you know or is it are we just getting
separate i don't know what it's getting
but the shit's got me curious
and i hope elon buys twitter dude that's
what i hope
and sinks that [ __ ] hole
cause those people have [ __ ] with free
speech more than anybody in the entire
world
and i hope somebody shuts that [ __ ]
down
i don't know how we ever got into some
of this situation i do not know
but
i i do man i hope elon buys twitter
and uh
untweets that hole in business that's
what i hope
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy
give it a try and see if online therapy
can help lower your stress that's right
better help if you are
in need of someone to talk to or be with
if you don't want to be alone
uh
you know or if you just something's
bothering you
don't let it bother you
you know i say stay busy that helps
um and if you need someone to talk to
then get them
and better help can do it
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy give it a try
see if it can help lower your stress
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and this past weekend listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
theo
fellas have you started your spring
cleaning yet
you got to clean up that crotch baby
that sea roch
you got to clean up down there by that
rattler in that bag daddy get it that's
right the carpets need cleaning to the
drapes match the hair on your back
that's what i want to know benjamin
manscaped has the full package you need
for spring cleaning this year the
performance package 4.0 is the only tool
you need to keep your boys looking and
smelling like the fresh tulips that your
partner wants
clear your holes and smell the spring
air with that weed whacker yep the nose
and ear hair trimmer some people you
can't even hear a certain thing because
you got so much hair on you
your ear look like it's growing a
little ewok or something growing a
little mitten
you know you'll see somebody put both
their hands in your ear to stay warm and
you're like damn
but they just trying on that mitt
finish off your grooming routine with
the plow 2.0 the perfect razor
for the finest shave on your face get
your face well
that's right manscape has it all it's
testicular cancer awareness month in
april test your nuts out
or have your buddy test them manscaped
has partnered with testicular cancer
society they're bringing awareness
checking nuts out
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code th eo at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code theo at
manscape.com it's time to throw out
your old high gain habits and upgrade
your life
yeah i i think it's interesting that um
that elon is trying to buy twitter i
like it
you know i like to see
you know free speech has been it's not
what it used to be
it's not
um
you know in a lot of media it's all
owned by the same
couple of organizations and
types of people
and um
and you're not you're not allowed to say
certain things
you know i know on twitter they shut
down
certain political views and political uh
stories they won't even let them be
shared on there
whereas other ones they will
you know certain schools of thought and
ideas they won't allow
and others they will
and it's a dump it's a dump and it's
just about power and control
um
[Music]
and people are sick of it people are i
mean it's literally making people sick
you know you take away somebody's voice
and it uh
for some of us all it's the only thing
you have that's yours
you know and i've been a victim of not a
v i've been a pr i've been a contributor
of it myself and being afraid to even
say what i really want to say sometimes
being afraid to speak up for myself
afraid that i won't be able to
that i lose my ability to even have a
job or have a space
you know um
and that's scary
i mean that is uh
it's [ __ ] up
so any chance i see where somebody
who wants to even the score a little bit
is trying to make that happen
i like that because you put so much
pressure on
you you make things so unfair for so
long
i just don't think it's gonna end well
and
um
and i don't know what exactly that means
but
but damn i mean you're gonna see
you know if people can't speak at a
certain point they're gonna
they're gonna fight for their voice
i think
um
so more power to him
you know
i think uh
twitter's long been a [ __ ]
it's long been a [ __ ] um
and so
i hope elon flushes it
uh what else here man a lot of great
calls that have come in you know and i
hate to not be able to get to all of
them uh
let's take another
call
the one what dude
it's brandon out of amarillo
brandon baby out of amarillo
that's a spanish animal baby
that's a good place down there i think
i've never been onward
getting excited to see that uh that
dallas show boy
man real excited you're coming down here
to texas just wanted to call let you
know who's listening out here
man i'm a commercial painter i hear you
talking to my earbuds every day dude
gets me through the day
keeps my mind out of the out of the dark
arch you feel me but uh
man just appreciate everything getting
excited to see it
gang baby thanks brandon yeah i'm
looking forward to that too down there
in dallas at the wynn spear and it's a
beautiful venue
uh what else do we have to say here what
else is going on
[Music]
gang hey phil what's up man uh
just getting ready to do a little pre
pre-easter egg hunt with the kids with
them
uh single dad so i don't get to
have them every weekend but anyways i
just wanted to ask you and your
listeners like uh
what are some things that they did uh
your parents
or relatives did for easter
like we always
hit eggs and you find them some have
chocolates some have
i guess other things but um
a big thing i guess in asian culture
thai culture we had uh
our parents hide money in the plastic
game so
some of them would have panties i think
one of them i found had a ten dollar
bill which
that [ __ ] was gold when you were like
you know
four
or five
oh yeah baby that's beautiful
and y'all did it and y'all tie
you guys are tired because you sound
white you shocked everybody when you
tied us when you tied out there
um
yeah what did we do you know my mother
would make easter baskets
you know and hide them
um
and what else would we do we probably
had to clean usually my
my mom made us clean a lot so
i didn't mind cleaning because you get
the fumes baby i put the you get those
fumes going in the bathroom i'd be in
there pouring bleach
i'd pour bleach in the toilet and stir
it with that uh cleaner thing a little
cleaner stick
and just
let's get that hit baby
that hot bowl hit son
get that easter that freaking
resurrection bro
right up in my lungs baby
let the lord show up in your lungs
so yeah i think we would clean on easter
and we would probably just play spend
time with our neighbors
you know people would burn stuff in a
ditch around then because it was spring
cleaning
so you'd see a lot of ditch fires
and we would uh
after the fires would down down you know
go down a lot of us would get wet and
get out in there and
get the ash on ourselves do ash
wednesday ash thursday ash sunday ass
tuesday we'd be out there damn ashed out
you know
i mean we look you almost look black to
a lot of people some some i remember a
black mother neighborhood told us to
[ __ ] get in the house we're like
we're not even your kids
so we get all you know
we just party with whatever was in the
ditch usually
because springtime people did spring
cleaning people throw stuff in a ditch
and then burn it
so you'd either get a pile of ash or you
get stuff that wasn't burned yet
get you half a shifter robe or something
get that [ __ ] going you know you sit
out there and play office or you know
get you half a desk or something
you play a doctor or
you know uh
uh
planned parenthood you do play different
games out there business games
but we enjoyed it man we really enjoyed
it and i'm glad the thai people you guys
did it too i don't know what you guys
are up to on easter
you know i know you guys like to chop up
those eggs and put them in the uh
um
that shrimp stir-fry and i like that
thank you for that
one of my favorite things about
asian cultures how they chop that egg up
and sneak it in a meal
they'll sneak that [ __ ] into anything
son
that's easter all the time when you're
asian they're hot egging anything
they'll hide egg in any damn meal
it'll be june or it'll be august and
you'll find egg and something
that's beautiful
uh let's get one more call here
what up the uh smurf
from mary ghetto ohio
what's up murph out there in ohio
and we're happy you're alive baby gang
just wanted to call in listen to bird
necking
and your ayahuasca talk man it's dope as
[ __ ] because
it really resonates with me i had issues
with my mom and
she was an addict and
people don't really understand how that
disconnects you from
modern day adulthood but
hey man shout out you're doing big
things you're helping people
to hear it from someone like you is
very humbling and
feels cool man i appreciate you
later dog
oh gang bro thank you for the nice words
man you know i'm sorry a lot of these
calls are about me i guess today uh
and i'm sorry that your mother suffers
from addiction man oh
you know it breaks it breaks my heart
honestly um
it's just so powerful it's so powerful
people don't know
people don't know
and when you do struggle from it the
pain that an addict feels
that they can't love somebody that they
have trouble loving that they have
trouble connecting i mean
i don't know what's the tougher side of
the coin
to be the one that doesn't get the
connection to be the one that can't even
give it
you know there's just there's some break
in how we're doing things there's some
disconnect that we don't see overall
we're missing something
as a specie
and uh
and i'm sorry i'm sorry that your mother
dealt
has dealt with that and that you've had
to deal with that man i bet you're an
awesome guy and uh awesome son
and yeah we'll just keep it going how
about that gang
all right let's hit one more here and
thank you guys as always hotline
985-664-9503
[Music]
it's actually from albany georgia i just
had a quick hey ashley
and i sedated my first girl uh first
girlfriend named ashley actually and um
and it was a woman
and uh
beautiful gal sweet gale
and uh anyway
you're a man and i'm happy you're here
too as well brother uh gang baby onward
question for you uh my assistant at work
has been taking really long bathroom
breaks
dude goes like maybe three times a day
for like an hour at a time i mean it by
half the time at work uh seems like he's
in the
in the toilet but uh i just was
wondering uh what should i say should i
say something to him or
i don't know it's just kind of weird and
i just thought your take would be good
on it all right anyway love uh love the
show and i just
gang baby thank you i didn't mean to cut
you off dude but uh
but i did on accident and i don't even
know if i did it on accident but um
yeah bro first of all obviously this
could be kevin burling dawg okay
this could be kevin burling in there
he got that surprise party in his bottom
bruh
you know what i'm saying he got that
ta-da
in his colon dog he came might not be
able to handle the work environment
and this is the kind of employees you
get these days some guys they come they
clock in they [ __ ]
you have a dude at work for six hours
he's [ __ ] for four hours bruh
and you gotta pay him and then he wants
uh child support
you like child support he's like yeah
i'm dropping these kids off at the pool
son
and they'll take you to damn court
that's kevin burling dawg
this is the this is the issue with the
this is the issue with today man you
can't even find somebody that wants to
show up and do work
people pay want you to pay them the [ __ ]
that's the world we live in
people saying hey give me thirty dollars
an hour bruh i'll open my ass up over at
your office you're like what
and they want all medical
they want medical and dental
they want dental bruh
and all they doing is [ __ ]
they want dental bruh
if all you doing at work is doing booty
and you want dental bruh that's messed
up and you know it is
it just i i don't know when it ends man
and i don't know how you handle it
you can't say nothing else sue you
say they won't let you won't let them uh
do bowels at work
you won't let them have a bm a natural
bm at work
you'll be on their bm suppressor they
call you
or that booty oppressor
they're saying you caging up their
bowels
you know
they out there faking crohn's disease
and doing all that just it's hard to be
an employer these days
because people want you to pay them the
[ __ ]
you hear me people want you to pay them
to [ __ ] man
and some of it is because of this
japanese stuff the only fans
they got women on there they're getting
paid to do it a man sees that
and now he clocks in over there with you
he works over there at snap all or
whatever over construction stuff
you know he's over there at the
caterpillar plant
and he's over there you know
doing booty over there and wanting you
know about paid by the hour
it's a tough world man it's a tough
world for people just trying to navigate
it
but uh don't give up on yourselves if
you are
um
it's just a weird world and i think we
have to laugh at it we gotta laugh and
say man the world is weird
the world is weird and i need to laugh
at it more
because i let it get too serious for me
and uh
when i laugh at it it takes the
it takes that stinger off the
off of life
when i laugh at it so
but at least big jesus christo just
popped by and let us know he's still in
the game
at least he just stopped by and let us
know hey
don't forget about your dog you know
that time trumper you know one way to
to beat the system
so
all right we're going to find our way
out of this episode here uh
and we'll kind of it will come in a
little bit this is uh the unacoustic
version of stonekeepers
there is a light from stonekeepers and
david manuel
ah we got david spade in studio next
week and also i wanna if you have if you
know someone who has a very unique job
and a unique personality
um hit up the producer email we're
looking right now to um find somebody
who's worked in trauma trauma cleanup or
uh
you know crime scene and um
people that's doing hoarding that type
of cleanup
you know uh we're looking for somebody
in that position
uh that's in somewhere in the central
east area or in the los angeles area
and then we're looking also maybe
somebody that's run a pawn shop
or managed a pawn shop or
a renaissance faire
those are some unique jobs we'd like to
investigate
so if you know someone in one of those
realms
who has a unique personality we want
somebody who's good at sharing their
story and and at uh talking and
being communicative you know we don't
want no kevin burling out there
you know we don't want to know somebody
who's you know you hit him with a candle
and a cake and they [ __ ] can't handle
it
you know then they're in the [ __ ] for
an hour we don't want that
we want somebody who's just got light
battles
and enjoys uh
the birthday song
you guys be good to yourself man you
deserve it baby gang i'll see you guys
in uh
in one of those cities i'm coming to uh
soon
thank you
[Music]
whenever you're down
out in the cold
faithless and dark
your story's untold
[Music]
there is a light
[Music]
you see we'll find a place
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
be
guys
searching for peace
[Music]
it's getting a little bit gay for me
dude honestly
but
whatever uh
praise baby you guys be good thank you
guys for being a part of the episode
thank you guys for being a part of my
life uh we'll see y'all next week be
good to yourself baby you deserve it
gang